in the may 6th local election bonanza
this is the place to watch if you want
to find out if labour has a fighting
chance against the conservatives in
england last time around labour's red
wool was breached
when tory candidate and former john
lewis boss andy street
won the race to be mayor of the west
midlands natalie and burn must prove
that labour can win back
those disaffected voters i think most
people in the labour movement know that
the the race in the west midlands is
probably the most important race this
year
that labour contends um you know the
defeat that we had in
in december 2019 was really significant
and a lot of people actually in the
media and elsewhere have
underestimated um quite the you know the
depth of that defeat
there's been some criticism about
kirsten's leadership
about people not knowing what he stands
for
do you think that's fair when we take
care out and about in the west midlands
through
which i'm walking through markets and
that kind of thing um
there's a real enthusiasm to actually
you know come over have a chat
um listen talk share some views he's
clever
he's intelligent and he's
straightforward anybody who's kind of
watching
prime minister's questions and just
watching the forensic way he
he takes a takes apart boris the
blusterer
um you know people just sort of respect
that at the same time though
you're obviously critical of boris
johnson but he did manage to take six
seats off labor
at the last election in 2019 in your
area it feels like people in the west
midlands might quite like the idea boris
johnson as well
i spent more time on the streets of the
west midlands during that election than
pretty much any other politician in our
region
and i can tell you overwhelmingly what
people talked about
was brexit and jeremy corbyn
um and even amongst many tories i met
people who said you know they'd always
been voting tory you tended to find
people say well we do kind of think that
it's time for a change
i'm afraid we don't like mr corbin um
and
people would often describe boris as a
bit of a clown
and so they they weren't in love with
that they did want to get brexit done
and you know the
truth was they didn't trust our leader
at the time you should beat andy street
easily then is that what you're
anticipating yeah it is yeah i mean you
know obviously
it's difficult when you don't have polls
we've found door knocking has gone
really well people are quite keen uh
people are
quite pleased to see us kind of turn up
um and our numbers coming back look
great so yeah i think we're gonna i
think we're gonna
we'll do well what do you think the main
issues are
have you that you're fighting on in the
west midlands the number one issue by a
mile
is jobs jobs jobs people are super
worried about
um the economy uh the livelihoods of
small business
and basically how we get on it back on
our feet as fast as possible
the conservative party candidate is duly
elected
as mayor for the west midlands combined
authority
andy street who narrowly won the 2017
election to become the region's first
mayor
agrees that recovery from coronavorus
needs to be the priority
so i think there's one overwhelming
issue sophie and that's
how we're going to bounce back from the
pandemic so obviously this was a region
that was performing very well before the
pandemic but we've had a horrible
swipe swipe left from the pandemic lots
of job losses so the big question is
who is going to lead the economic
recovery of this region
this um contest is also going to be
looked through the prism of boris
johnson versus kirstama
as well you know it's a region that is a
key electoral battleground for both
parties
both labor and conservatives really need
to win it frankly the conservatives
obviously did better
in 2019. how do you think kiss dharma
goes down in the red wall then
i'm waiting to see the answer to that
this election will tell us something
about that
what i hope it will tell us is actually
the
idea that we did very well in the red
wall on the back of
brexit and the feeling about jeremy
corbyn and that was about it i think we
will prove that's wrong
i think what's going to be proved is
that support for the conservative party
in the areas that we describe as the
report is actually about something much
much deeper and primarily it's about
local conservatives
whether they be mps mayors or local
councils
really delivering for people if you
think of the investment
that's come into the black country come
into northfield the only
seat that we want in birmingham come
into these areas there is
clear evidence that conservatives
deliver
for the areas that arguably left behind
that's what it's really all about
i've just spoke to liam byrne before
talking to you
i have to say he seemed pretty confident
he seemed to think that he was going to
win
quite comfortably are you worried i
don't think anyone's going to win
comfortably i think it's going to be
very very close
race the last mayoral race was very
close the general election was very
close here
so i'm prepared to predict it'll be
close again
and uh i'm actually quite surprised that
he was competent because
i think the feedback i get is that it's
really really contested
we are confident of our position but no
it's going to be very very
close in the end to give a sense of how
close
this race could be there are 28
westminster constituencies across the
region that the west midlands mayor
controls
in the last general election in 2019 14
of them were won by the conservative
party
the other 14 were won by labour nearly
1.2 million votes were cast but there
was less than 3
000 votes between the two main parties
and the west midlands was part of a
wider story
six previously labor seats some of which
have been held by the party for decades
turned blue as boris johnson ate into
the so-called red wall
and it's this that gives the west
midlands race an added significance it
will be an indicator of how far boris
johnson has kept those red wool voters
on side
and a test of kierstama's ability to win
them back to labour
it will be a setback for the government
if they don't hold this everything
suggests it's going to be tight
it was tight last time around when andy
street uh managed this surprise victory
you've got really uh factors on either
side that are quite hard to calculate
on his side he's very popular for his
business background for the
john lewis history that he has for the
real efforts that he's made to improve
uh the area but he's been quite quiet
he's a reserved personality
and he's had what you might say as a
handicap um
during the pandemic of coming from the
same party as the government
that's not a problem that has affected
labour mayors i think it is the kind of
place where kyocera has to
show that he's he's getting through to
people that he's got something to say
the race for the west midlands is
unusually seen as a must win for both
parties whatever happens on the 6th of
may
it's likely to be very close